what's your name kid the human spider  a human spider that's it that's the best  you got yeah oh that sucks  the sum of three thousand dollars will  be paid to  the terrifying  the deadly  the  amazing spider-man  my name's the human spider i don't care  get out no he got my name wrong  [Applause]  gonna eat you up and spit you out little  man i hope you brought your mommy wicked  [Applause]  oh my god  all my legs oh god i can't feel my legs  [Applause]  hey  [Applause]  hey listen it's some kind of mistake i  didn't sign up for cage match  hey  unlock the thing take the chain off hey  break joe  you're going nowhere  i got you for three minutes  three minutes of plea time  [Applause]  what are you doing up there staying away  from you  that's a cute outfit did your husband  give it to you  [Applause]  ugh  [Applause]  yes  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  do